i used to really love chinese food until  it started a global pandemic  i'll think i'll stick with mexican food  from now on  burritos have never prevented me from  seeing tennant in theaters  i feel like people are afraid to blame  china for the coronavirus because they  don't want to appear racist but i say  let them have it  they deserve it  you know chinese people love what  markets so much they even put their  uyghurs in them  um  people are like oh look china can build  a hospital in 10 days yeah if you're  eating bats and penguins you better be  able to build a hospital in 10 days  all right thank you  wow hans kim everybody with a brand new  minute